règlement mes chers collègues de gauche
vous surjouez le 46 bis
vous surjouez l'indignation
chers collègues de gauche et vous faites
mine d'être surpris mais vous ne l'êtes
pas
l'application du vote bloqué c'est la
Constitution
ça n'est pas une application il libérale
de notre loi fondamentale ici nous
sommes sur la 5e République nous ne
sommes pas sous la Quatrième République
l'application du vote bloqué la cause
c'est vous c'est votre obstruction vous
avez donné votre version des faits je
vous donne notre version des faits bien
sûr jusqu'à mardi 7 mars tout se passait
bien puisque nous avions un engagement
vous souhaitiez discuter et que l'on
vote l'article 7 pas avant le 7 nous
nous sommes tu pas bâillonner nous nous
sommes tu pour respecter notre
engagement et ensuite vous n'avez tenu
aucun de vos engagements très vite où
nous sommes aperçus que vous vouliez
nous empêcher d'aller au bout de
débattre du fond et de voter le texte
l'obstruction c'est quand on dépose
449 demandes de rapport l'obstruction
c'est quand on multiplie des amendements
identiques des sous amendements
ridicules qui n'apportent rien des
rappels au règlement qui n'en sont pas
ça c'est de l'obstruction et
l'obstruction finalement c'est la
négation du rôle du Parlement vous
transformez le Sénat en un groupe de
parole le Parlement ne vaut bien sûr
qu'avec les débats pour éclairer la
délibération et le vote c'est notre
métier c'est notre devoir le devoir que
nous avons pris par rapport au français
mes chers collègues et on ne peut pas
dans une enceinte parlementaire on ne
peut pas supporter qu’une minorité
prenne en otage une majorité par le seul
fait par le seul fait que vous devriez
pas être perdant nous voulons voter et
je vous rappelle rapidement qu'au Sénat
la gauche à utiliser neuf fois le vote
bloqué et qu'elle Assemblée nationale
sur la loi Touraine c'était aussi cette
application